this is my ship still I'm in charge I
know I know of course you are
of course see you say of course but then
you touch the map it makes you think
that maybe you didn't realize I was in
charge at equator that's your own well
here it is in there okay I'm merely
trying to be of service of the system
quill that's what I said you should
fight one another for the honor of
leadership it sounds fair it's not
necessary it's not okay I got some
blasters unless you guys want to use
knives oh yes please use knives no no
[Laughter]
there should be no knifing one another
everybody knows who's in charge
me yes welcome back everyone it's
Charlie Happy New Year this is gonna be
my video all about Thor for love and
thunder and Christian Bale apparently
he's up for a role in the film if you
could ever believe it he's coming to the
Marvel Universe so we'll break it down
if you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
we're also doing a movie ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know in the video
who you want Christian Bale to play in
Thor for if you remember a couple years
ago Christian Bale has been asked a lot
after he did the Dark Knight trilogy and
played Batman whether or not he would do
more Batman or more superhero movies if
he'd ever be in a Marvel movie because
by the time he finished Dark Knight
Rises the Marvel Cinematic Universe had
really started to take off it was still
phase one early phase two days so they
didn't have quite the clout and they
weren't quite as big as they are today
and even as recently as 2017 Christian
Bale had said he had no interest in
working with Marvel on a superhero movie
in the only real superhero movies that
he'd ever watched his entire life were
the Christopher Reeve Superman films and
his Batman Dark Knight films so
everyone's wondering what just happened
to change that in which character he
would be playing so what probably
happened is as tyka offered him a
one-off
role like Cate Blanchet coming in to do
hella during thor ragnarok you could say
that she could come back because
technically she's the goddess of death
and can you really kill the goddess of
death technically no but they wrote that
role for Cate Blanchet so that she
wouldn't have to come back she only
signed a contract for that one movie so
that's why they killed her off at the
end of the movie in the way that they
did so that was kind of ambiguous you
could say that she's dead and if she
never came back she would just stay dead
but if she suddenly wanted to be in
another Marvel movie again they would
totally find a place to put her and just
say no she didn't die so that's the
trick that they used to get big
Hollywood actors on board who wouldn't
necessarily want to sign on for a four
or five picture deal like a standard
actor would when they're becoming an MCU
character the other way they convinced
them to do movies like this is if they
have friends that are also making the
movie either the directors their
personal friend or their friends with
the star
like that's how Chris Hemsworth got Matt
Damon during Thor Ragnarok in that funny
play you may have seen that funny home
video that Chris Hemsworth posted of him
and Matt Damon just shooting arrows at
each other playing around their friends
in real life their families go on
vacations together so when they were
making Thor Ragnarok he was like hey do
you want to come play this fake version
of Loki and just have fun for a little
while no big commitment it just for this
one movie remember how Ryan Reynolds got
Brad Pitt to be in Deadpool to as the
Vanisher character it was a hilarious
cameo and he was only on screen for a
brief period the reason why Brad Pitt
did that is because his kids are big
fans of the Deadpool franchise not
because he cares or he was potentially
going to earn a bunch of money he just
did it as a favor to Ryan Reynolds
because his kids were big fans so odds
are no matter who Christian Bale would
be playing it's probably just gonna be
for this one film because I do think
that he still kind of has a lot of
disdain for big superhero franchises and
he doesn't want to sign on for some huge
commitment that's why I don't think the
character he's up for is beta ray bill
because I think they intend to use beta
ray bill in all kinds of different
space-based movies like guardians of the
galaxy would be a great franchise to put
him in even if they don't do more
Guardian films after Guardian 3 you
still have a Guardians team flying
around out there they just pop up in
cameo every once in a while and you
cycle the roster beta ray bill was even
a member of the guardians of the galaxy
recently in the comics the character I
think it makes more sense for Christian
Bale to be playing if he's gonna be
playing say like a villain character
would be Daario agar
the CEO of Roxon the Minotaur of
for those of you that haven't read the
Thor comics he was one of the first big
villains that Jane Foster Thor faced
when they did the female Thor in the
comics a few years ago they have a lot
of characters in the movie who are
either from earth or on planet earth
after the events of Avengers endgame in
new Asgard is still on earth up in
coastal Norway so it makes sense that
the main villain of the movie or one of
the villains at least would also come
from Earth and because it's a Thor movie
you typically do new characters that
flow from that type of mythology so the
Minotaur of Roxon would be a great
character to introduce he would look
like Christian Bale for most of the
movie because Dario agar walks around
looking like a normal human but then
during the big final battle with Thor
and Jane Foster female Thor he goes into
his full Minotaur form and it becomes
more of a motion-capture fight like when
Mark Ruffalo is doing the Hulk or when
taike is playing Korg and if you weren't
sure obviously Korg and meek are gonna
come back for Thor for they still need
to get their revenge on noob master
speaking of new master everybody's been
making Deadpool jokes wouldn't it be
funny if Deadpool in the MCU eventually
when they introduced Deadpool in to the
MCU winds up secretly being noob masters
so they weave him into the history of
the MCU in a really clever way how angry
do you think that everyone would be if
Christian Bale is just up for the new
master role and he's only in it for a
one-off joke for like two seconds
but Roxon is a company that's shown up
all over the Marvel Universe in the MCU
and the TV shows in present-day and
going back to the 1940s during the
events of the agent Carter TV series
their big oil and gas company they're
known for exploiting the earth's
resources in there a lot of films right
now the big franchise films that are
trading on themes of climate change like
James Cameron's Avatar sequels and it
just makes sense that they would do
something like that with these Thor
characters if all the pieces line up
there were a lot of you that were asking
me if he's playing Gore the god butcher
the reason why I don't think that he's
playing Gore is because they kind of
already gave most of the aspects of that
character to the Helicarrier during Thor
Ragnarok and Gore as a character isn't
really integral to the female Jane
Foster Thor origin story and that's
supposed to be a big part of the film so
just explain the basic plot outline that
tyka gave us back at Comic Con this is
basically what's going on with Thor for
love and thunder they're doing the Jane
Foster female Thor origin story from the
comics
it'll be a little bit different from the
comic book version but they did say that
they might do the cancer plot they're
still kind of deciding on that because
they're not gonna be shooting the movie
for a little while the biggest changes
they're making to that or that that
story happened the reason why Jane
Foster became Thor is because Thor
became unworthy during a big comic book
event the hammer passed to Jane Foster
in Thor didn't wield any hammer for a
long time in the comic eventually he did
get it back he got a shiny gold arm with
a gold hammer and Jane Foster became the
new version of Valkyrie but MC youth or
after Avengers endgame is still worthy
he's still wildung Stormbreaker and they
destroyed Mjolnir during Thor Ragnarok
so there are a lot of things that they
had to set up at the beginning of the
film like what hammer is Jane Foster
Thor going to wield the only options for
that are bringing one from the
multiverse if you're talking about Loki
from Avengers and game the one that
escaped with the tesseract creating that
alternate timeline we'll see him again
during the Loki series and maybe during
Doctor Strange 2 they also had to follow
up with Valkyrie being the new queen of
Asgard in what they're gonna do with
Asgard going forward because Thor 4 is
being released a couple years after the
end of Avengers endgame I'm assuming
that a couple years will have gone by so
Valkyrie will have been queen of Asgard
for a little while and Thor will have
lost most of his weight on the Bowflex
that he borrowed from star-lord
initially their plans for guardians 3
were a little bit different in terms of
the timing so I think there was gonna be
a Thor follow-up scene that would set
him up for Thor for love and thunder
before they changed the release date for
guardians 3 now that's all kind of up in
the air so they'll had to have some sort
of scene to follow up and explain what
happened with Thor in the as guardians
of the galaxy while he was out with them
but then the big question is is what
happens to Chris Hemsworth's
Thor going forward is he returning
during Avengers 5 maybe he also gets a
cameo when they eventually introduced
Galactus and Silver Surfer because he
spent a lot of time in the comics
crossing over with those two characters
in speaking of Galactus if you're really
hyped up about him entering the MCU they
just did a Thor story they rebooted the
character a new rider came on the title
Galactus crossed over I won't spoil the
story but it's crazy but because there's
a lot of confusion about what's going on
with female Thor Jane Foster the idea is
is that Thor in the MCU is not unworthy
will not become unworthy so the
why she winds up picking up the hammer
is gonna be a little bit different from
the comics I think there are a lot of
people that are just confused about how
this is going to work because of the way
it went down in the comics so if you
never read the female Thor comic book
don't worry you won't have to read that
to understand what's going on at the
beginning of Thor for if they give us
any more details about what's going on
with the movie or they confirm any more
castings and characters and people
coming back I'll totally include it one
of my Marvel videos but everyone let me
know in the comments if you have any
special requests for future Marvel
videos and every one click here for my
Marvel New Mutants trailer video which
is actually a real movie that's coming
out in theaters believe it or not and
click here for my brand-new Doctor
Strange 2 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome Happy
New Year
[Music]